Massengräber im Kiefernwald
Ermittler am Rande der Erschöpfung
Städte in Trümmern
traumatisierte Überlebende
[Musik]
ukrainische Soldaten die ihr Land
befreien und auf weitere westliche
Waffen drängen
in der Ukraine bin ich Menschen begegnet
die kämpfen trauern und doch
weitermachen auch unter schwierigsten
Bedingungen
[Musik]
16 September der Weg zurück ins Leben
führt über die Brücke über den Fluss
Donez fast sechs Monate herrschten
russische Soldaten über die Stadt isium
war eine der Knotenpunkte für den Krieg
jetzt weht wieder die ukrainische Flagge
über den Häusern
panisch sollen Putins Soldaten vor der
ukrainischen Armee geflohen sein was sie
hinterlassen sind Trümmer Tote und
traumatisierte
wie war die Situation hier
ist alles begonnen hat
es war schrecklich
verstehen sie es tut immer noch weh ich
kann das nicht begreifen
und jetzt ist es schwer
wir haben das Haus verloren und jetzt
braucht uns keiner
aber wir halten durch und sind froh dass
die Ukraine gekommen sind wir haben
gewartet
Präsident selenski hat gesagt das hier
seit zweimal Butcher stimmt das ja
Zerstörung Tod von Menschen Terror ich
stimme dem Zug
sie haben den Terror selbst erlebt
wir haben den Terror erfahren von den
Soldaten als wir im Dorf gelebt haben
sie kamen mit Durchsuchungen zu uns mit
Gewehren liefen durch das Haus und
machten den Kindern Angst
so war es das ist alles was ich dazu
sagen kann als Frau hat man ihnen etwas
angetan nein Gott sei Dank ist nichts
dergleichen passiert ich werde nicht
lügen
mein Mann war mit mir und wir haben es
durchgehalten
was denken sie über die Zukunft oder
über die Situation ich weiß nicht was
die Zukunft für mich bereithält ich
möchte an das beste glauben aber jetzt
ist es schwierig ich kann immer noch
nicht die innere Kraft finden um
weiterzuleben
arbeiten Sie hier ich habe früher als
ukrainischlehrerin gearbeitet sie haben
meine Schule zerstört ich würde gerne
wieder arbeiten und kinderunterrichten
meine eigenen Kinder gehen nicht zur
Schule ich hoffe dass es solche
Möglichkeit geben wird
danke alles Gute bitte danke Ihnen
[Musik]
die Schule ist zerstört und die Kinder
haben in sechs Monaten ihre Kindheit
verloren
wie blickst du in die Zukunft
ich möchte einfach ein friedliches Leben
wie alt bist du 14 Jahre
du warst ein halbes Jahr nicht in der
Schule nein
ich konnte die achte Klasse nicht
beenden niemand wurde in die Schule
gelassen nachdem der Krieg begonnen hat
und sie angefangen haben zu schießen
die Schule ist dort zerstört alles ist
zerstört mein Onkel liegt unter Trümmern
begraben in einem fünfstöckigen Haus und
zwei Cousinen eine fünf Jahre alt die
andere Art
nicht einmal die orthodoxe Kirche haben
sie verschont im russischen Bombenhagel
wurden 80% der Bauten zerstört wie
sollen sie den Winter hier überstehen
und wer soll das alles wieder aufbauen
[Musik]
es ist fast gespenstisch still hier im
Zentrum von iseum die Menschen kehren
erst langsam wieder in ihre Stadt zurück
und die meisten werden Schwierigkeiten
haben hier so schnell wieder Fuß zu
fassen denn viele ihrer Häuser sind
komplett zerstört
in einem Hof treffe ich auf Menschen die
sich über Monate nur von Kartoffeln
Konserven und Gemüse aus dem Garten
ernährt haben ein paar Stufen geht es
hinunter in die völlige Dunkelheit wo
ich auf Anja treffe mit 60 anderen
Menschen hat sie sich hier über Monate
versteckt
gibt es hier immer noch kein Licht nein
hier gibt es kein Licht kein Wasser kein
Gas wir haben nichts
irgendwann erhält das Licht unserer
Kamera den Keller noch hatten sie keine
Zeit aufzuräumen noch ist vieles so
geblieben wie sie es zum Überleben
brauchten es kostet Anja Kraft zu
erzählen von Hunger Durst und
schlaflosen Nächten voller Angst
was denken Sie jetzt über diese Russen
man darf es nicht laut sagen ich weiß
nicht was die sich gedacht haben
als sie sie gesehen haben hatten sie den
Eindruck dass sie wussten was sie hier
tun eine Vorstellung davon hatten
ich weiß nicht was Sie gedacht haben ich
will niemanden verteidigen ich weiß
nicht was man denken kann wenn man
losgeht um andere Menschen zu töten ich
will es mir nicht einmal vorstellen
unterwegs in den Kiefernwald von isium
wo die Toten liegen verscharrt unter
namenlosen kreuzen
Stuttgart Journalisten aus aller Welt
haben die Ukraine hierhin gebracht wo
nun die Toten geborgen werden
hinter uns liegt ein Friedhof in dem
sich Dutzende von Massengräbern befinden
die die Ermittler jetzt ausheben um jede
einzelne Leiche zu untersuchen
mehr als 450 tote sollen hier verschad
liegen die Staatsanwaltschaft untersucht
jetzt wegen Verdachts auf
Kriegsverbrechen
nun sagen wir mal so in dieser Stadt
arbeiten zehn Ermittler
staatsanwaltsgruppen parallel
der Zeit wurden zehn Gräber ausgehoben
und die Leichen tot hat Zivilisten
rausgeholt
jetzt werden sie von Rechtsmedizinern
untersucht
weitere 40 Gräber zu exformieren das
heißt weitere 50 Leichen
versuchen im Laufe der Woche das
Territorium komplett zu untersuchen und
alle Zivilisten zu exformieren
wenn ich es richtig verstehe waren das
die Russen
begraben
nach Informationen die uns vorliegen
wurden sie durch die Soldaten der
Russischen Föderation getötet
durch artillerieanschläge auf die Stadt
durch Luftangriffe
raketeneinschläger
weitere Zivilisten wurden zu Tode
gefoltert und hier begraben nach unseren
Informationen
in Plastiksäcken werden die Leichen zur
weiteren Untersuchung nach rakif
gebracht
Ukrainer sollen die Toten hier
verscharrt haben auf Befehl der Russen
so berichten es die Einwohner der
Polizei
es waren Mitarbeiter des örtlichen
Bestattungsinstitutes die im Auftrag
oder mit Zustimmung der
Besatzungsbehörden diese Arbeit
ausgeführt haben
wurde gegen sie ermittelt sie haben im
Prinzip ja für die Besatzer gearbeitet
ja natürlich diese Menschen werden
gerade vernommen
wurde in einem Grab eine oder mehrere
Leichen gefunden damit wir eine
Vorstellung von der Anzahl haben
indem die Bestatter die Nummer
zugewiesen und die bekannten Daten
angegeben haben
den Nachname den Vornamen das
Geburtsjahr des Verstorbenen
demnach halten wir fest dass es 445
Gräber gibt wir glauben dass es 445
Leichen geben wird
wenn wir jedoch nach dem Ausgraben dort
nicht eine sondern zwei Leichen haben
wird dies im Untersuchungsprotokoll
jedes Grabes entsprechend vermerkt
wann ist das was in einem Krieg passiert
ein Kriegsverbrechen mit aller Kraft
versuchen die Ukraine zu ermitteln zu
dokumentieren bis zur völligen
Erschöpfung weil die Welt ist wissen
soll und weil die Angehörigen auch das
brauchen Gewissheit
können Sie den Ermittlern helfen warum
sind sie hier
ist jetzt
weil uns gesagt wurde das ist wichtig
ist der Öffentlichkeit zu erzählen was
passiert ist ja hier sind meine Freunde
und meine Nachbarn
Gott sei Dank keine Verwandten
mein Vater ist in kobiansk gestorben er
war krank
und ihre Freunde die hier sind
es sind gute Menschen weniger Freunde
eher bekannte mein Nachbar aus demselben
Stockwerk wir haben bis zuletzt im
Hausflur geraucht ich habe ihm immer die
Zigaretten gegeben weil alle Geschäfte
zu waren
wir haben die Soldaten sich verhalten
wenn die Soldaten angetrunken waren
haben sie sogar unter sich gestritten
und aufeinander geschossen ihre
Vorgesetzten haben das gesehen und haben
verboten Alkohol zu verkaufen sie haben
trotzdem welche gesucht in der Stadt
wurde verboten Alkohol zu verkaufen weil
sie wirklich begonnen haben aufeinander
zu schießen wir hatten Angst rauszugehen
weil sie einfach begonnen haben
wurde ein paar Tage vor easium befreit
auch hier versuchen sie irgendwie wieder
im Leben anzukommen dazu gehört auch die
bittere Erkenntnis dass einige im Ort
mit dem Feind zusammengearbeitet haben
die Geschichte vom Bürgermeister der die
russischen Soldaten unterstützte hat
überall die Runde gemacht
es wurde erzählt dass er gesagt hat
passt auf diese Armee auf und behindert
sie nicht schließlich ist er mit seiner
Familie geflohen er hat wahrscheinlich
hier alle verraten die er verraten
konnte etwas später schrieb man dass er
mit seiner Familie in Belgorod ist
haben sie dicke litten unter den lokalen
Kollaborateuren als unter den russischen
Soldaten
Kollaborateure ja natürlich sie haben
uns das Geld entlockt die Russen haben
uns in Ruhe gelassen aber ich bin auch
nicht rausgegangen ich denke dass die
Kollaborateure auf jeden Fall bezahlt
wird
wie alleine gelassen sich viele Menschen
auch in balaklia fühlen erleben wir bei
unseren Begegnungen immer wieder
[Musik]
alina ist 15 und steht wie so viele
verloren am Straßenrand
sie haben alles geklaut zerstört haben
in fremden Häusern gewohnt haben
Menschen aus ihren Häusern vertrieben
konntest du mit deinen Freunden sprechen
nein das ging nicht aber jetzt
meine Freunde rufen mich an und fragen
was mit meinem Haus ist und ich sage ich
habe kein Zuhause
sie sagen ich soll zu ihm nach Hause und
dort wohnen aber sie kommen bald zurück
und wir werden kein Zuhause haben
[Musik]
8000 von 120000 Einwohnern sind in
balaklia zurückgeblieben vor allem alte
Frauen und Familien die nicht wussten
wohin was sie erlebt haben lässt sie
nicht los und die Furcht dass die Russen
zurückkehren könnten ist allgegenwärtig
wir hatten Angst haben uns versteckt
es wurde geschossen aber wir wollen ja
leben was sollen wir tun
unser Haus wurde beschädigt alles wurde
beschädigt
aber wir denken dass das Leben wieder
gut sein wird wir hoffen darauf
und die russischen Soldaten wie waren
die
ich weiß es nicht die wissen nicht woher
sie kamen
sie waren sehr jung Jungs eigentlich
warum sie geflohen sind
wir wissen es nicht sie waren hier und
auf einmal sind sie weg die ukrainische
Armee kam und das war's wir wissen
nichts wir haben sie begrüßt
plötzlich wird unser Gespräch vom Lärm
ukrainischer Militärlaster übertönt
Munitionskisten Uniformen eine Garage
mit der Aufschrift Minen so haben die
russischen Soldaten die Häuser
zurückgelassen alles sieht nach
panischer Flucht aus
wie war die Situation
die Situation war schwer das war sehr
schwer
Frauen haben sie in Ruhe gelassen kann
man sagen
zumindest das was wir gesehen haben
Männer ja insbesondere diejenigen die
die Ausgangssperre verletzt haben
es gab welche die durch den Posten
gegangen sind sie haben sie auf die Knie
gezwungen haben sie an den Händen
gefesselt es hat dort Schreie gegeben
da eine Hilfsorganisation ist nach
balaklia gekommen zum ersten Mal können
Sie Lebensmittel verteilen alles wird
gebraucht Mehl Öl auch Medikamente viele
haben sich über Monate versteckt nur wer
sich heraus traute konnte Lebensmittel
von den russischen Besatzern bekommen
die Russen haben uns welche gegeben
haben sie gebracht und verteilt hatten
sie genug zu essen
sie haben es einmal im Monat verteilt
Nudeln vielleicht ein halbes Kilo und
dann noch gezuckerte Kondensmilch Fisch
Makrele Dosenfleisch
das war einmal im Monat
was haben sie gerade bekommen
ich weiß nicht humanitäre Hilfe ich bin
reingegangen und wir haben es
rausgetragen
wir wissen nicht was drin ist was
brauchen sie jetzt
wir brauchen Ruhe Wasser Strom Heizung
und Frieden damit es keinen Beschuss
mehr gibt deshalb stottere ich jetzt
auch
mehr als sechs Monate haben die Menschen
hier in balaklia unter russischer
Besatzung gelebt nach dem Jubel über die
Befreiung kommt jetzt der Moment der
Zukunft die große Frage ist wie werden
die Menschen hier künftig weiterleben
überall im Land haben sich Menschen
zusammengetan um die Bedürftigen zu
versorgen in einer Lagerhalle in hakif
packen sie Windeln Babynahrung und
Kleidung sie nennen sich Mama mobil eine
Organisation die Mütter versorgt
zusammen Gutes tun ihr Motto kleben sie
an den Transporter mit dem sie auch
heute unterwegs sein werden
finanziert wird alles von Spenden wie
alle hier hat auch Alexandra alles
aufgegeben um denen zu helfen die
Unterstützung brauchen sie ist 29 vor
dem Krieg war sie Managerin
kann jede Mutter Hilfe von euch bekommen
oder muss sie in einer besonderen
Situation sein
Mütter die alleine in der Stadt
geblieben sind deren Ehemänner entweder
im Krieg sind oder die leider ihren Mann
verloren haben deshalb haben sie keine
Mittel um etwas zu kaufen und sie
brauchen es wirklich sehr
die Arbeit der Freiwilligen ist
gefährlich denn immer noch greifen die
Russen auch hakif mit Raketen an
kürzlich erst wurde das Mama mobil von
Splittern russischer Geschosse getroffen
die Alexandra mir zeigt an einem der
Punkte hielten sie an und es gab einen
Beschluss ein Kiosk wurde getroffen
buchstäblich 50 Meter entfernt die
Windeln haben unseren Jungs das Leben
gerettet weil alle Splitter in ihnen
stecken geblieben sind
sie waren dort drin wow die haben drei
Packungen durch Bord und sind in der
vierten stecken geblieben
ja aber ich ertrage es am schwersten
weil ich eine junge Frau bin wenn der
Beschuss in der Nähe ist nehme ich es
emotional schwer aber Gott sei Dank
wurde niemand körperlich verletzt alle
sind am Leben und wohlauf
[Musik]
an einem der verteilerpunkte in einem
Wohnviertel warten schon Frauen mit
ihren Kindern manche kommen regelmäßig
andere haben erst gerade von Mama mobil
erfahren
[Musik]
ohne sie wäre es sehr schwer gewesen wir
kommen jede Woche und sie unterstützen
uns psychologisch und physisch
ich habe drei Kinder
drei ja zwei sind zu Hause und der
kleinste Tier und der kleinste Junge
oder Mädchen wie alt ist es zwei Monate
das ist ein Junge
das bedeutet dass er schon im Krieg
geboren ist ja unter den Bomben wie kann
ich es mir vorstellen mit so einem
kleinen Kind zu leben
für sie leben wir wir bemühen uns passen
auf uns auf nur für die Kinder ja wieso
guten Tag ich sehe sie erwarten bald ein
Kind wann
gestern waren die neun Monate um
und wie fühlen sie sich
ich bin nervös aber ansonsten geht es
wir hoffen und warten
was ist das schwierigste in der
Situation für Sie
dass wir nicht wissen was morgen
passiert
was bedeutet es in diesem Krieg
schwanger zu sein für Kinder zu sorgen
der Krieg hat viele Frauen in alte
Rollenbilder zurückgeworfen die Väter
kämpfen sind weg sie bleiben mit den
Kindern alleine zurück
das ist sehr schwierig psychologisches
das schwierig mit dem Kind das Kind
erschreckt nachts wird durch die
Explosionen aufgeweckt
ich versuche das Kind zu beruhigen aber
wenn er tagsüber auf der Straße etwas
hört dann sagt er bumm bumm
bugabedit er hat sich schon daran
gewöhnt wenn es aber sehr nah und sehr
laut ist dann erschreckt er sich und
weint
wie alt ist er
ein Jahr und drei Monate
wie traumatisiert die Kinder vom Krieg
sind erlebe ich immer wieder bei meinen
Begegnungen hier wächst eine neue
traumatisierte Generation heran
ich bin Jäger ich habe dieses Bild
gemalt
ich habe es mir selbst ausgedacht es
sind unsere Ukrainer die Schießen auf
die schlechten sie erschießen sie
unsere ukrainischen Soldaten werden die
schlechte Armee wegräumen das heißt
töten
ich denke dass unsere ukrainischen
Soldaten siegen werden
guter Junge es lebe die Ukraine wenn ich
groß bin und alle Schulen hinter mir
habe gehe ich in den Krieg und werde
dort die Ukraine verteidigen
wir haben auch bekannte an der Front
Freunde deshalb weiß das Kind wie eine
Kalaschnikow aussieht wie man sie lädt
leider weiß er sowas mit sechs Jahren
ein Land eine Gesellschaft die versuchen
muss mit dem grauen und den Schrecken
des Krieges klarzukommen
Igor hat sein Bild Alexandra geschenkt
sie weiß viele Kinder haben ihre eigene
Strategie das alles zu verarbeiten
leider ja Kinderspiele haben sich
verändert sie spielen Kontrollposten
Soldaten sebasteln Schutzwesten aus
Eierkartons ja leider sind das jetzt die
Realitäten unseres Lebens aber es gibt
keinen Weg dem zu entkommen
dass sie erleben
Spuren bleiben für Kinder zu 100% und
für Erwachsene wahrscheinlich auch das
wird noch viele Jahre so bleiben
der Krieg bestimmt nun auch die Spiele
auf einer Straße in der Region habe ich
vor einigen Wochen Kinder getroffen die
an einem echten Checkpoint den die
Soldaten verlassen hatten Autos
kontrollieren mit plastikwaffen in
Uniform
wir sind die 17 Panzer Brigade auch in
unserer Schule haben wir diese Brigade
die Autofahrer lassen sich kontrollieren
ganz so als sei es ernst für mich die
Reporterin aus Deutschland nehmen sie
noch mal Aufstellung lassen sich
fotografieren und deine Eltern was
denken die darüber sie lassen es zu sie
mögen es wenn wir hier stehen okay und
so verbringen sie ihre Sommerferien im
festen Glauben ihrem Land dienen zu
können
Papa mir Sex gehört auf Deutsch
wir fahren weiter an die östliche Front
Kriegsgebiet hier müssen wir
schusssichere Westen tragen
wir sind verabredet mit einer Einheit
der Territorialverteidigung einer Gruppe
von Freiwilligen die die Ortschaften vor
den Russen schützen sollen
Keeper nennt sich ihr Chef er will uns
zeigen wie dringend sie hier westliche
Waffen brauchen bevor es losgeht gibt er
uns eine kurze Einweisung
wir fahren los und im Falle eines
Beschusses was bei der momentanen Lage
nicht passieren dürfte halten wir das
Fahrzeug an alle steigen aus und legen
sich auf den Boden wir suchen nicht nach
einem sicheren Unterschlupf sondern
legen uns einfach hin alles klar
wir folgen dem Kommandanten Skipper ist
42 und eigentlich Anwalt er hat sich wie
alle in seiner Einheit freiwillig zum
Einsatz in diesem Krieg gemeldet und wie
alle hier hat er einen Kampfnamen mehr
als ihre Kalaschnikow haben sie nicht an
Ausrüstung in einem kleinen Waldstreifen
zwischen den Äckern haben sie
Schützengräben ausgehoben immer wieder
werden sie von den Russen angegriffen
dann bleibt Ihnen nur in den Gräben
Schutz zu suchen
in diese Richtung ja sie schießen aus
großer Entfernung die geschützte stehen
20 Kilometer von hier und schießen in
diese Richtung
es ist ein ungleicher Kampf das wissen
sie gerade ist hier alles ruhig das
Getreide steht schon hoch aber ernten
wird es wohl niemand die Männer zeigen
uns die Einschlagstelle einer Granate
ganz in der Nähe aber auch die geächtete
Phosphor Munition die alles verbrennt
setzen die Russen ein sagen sie weil die
Felder schon trocken sind und dann
schneller Feuer fangen
gegen uns eingesetzt wir haben das helle
aufleuchten gesehen so führen sie den
Krieg
die Brutalität in diesem Krieg nimmt
immer weiter zu die Soldaten zeigen uns
Videos von Granaten die neben ihrer
Stellung eingeschlagen sind
worüber sie nicht so gerne sprechen auch
bei ihnen gab es Opfer 12 tote 70
verletzte dass sie alle hier ihr Leben
riskieren schwer vorstellbar für
Deutsche die seit Jahrzehnten im Frieden
leben sie leben im Frieden sie bauen
ihre Wirtschaft immer weiter aus wir
sind in einer anderen Phase wir müssen
den Feind besiegen und dann die
Demokratie aufbauen die Soldaten der
territorialkräfte nehmen uns mit in
eines der Dörfer als die Angriffe der
Russen besonders schlimm waren hatten
sie den Ort evakuiert jetzt sind fast
alle Bewohner wieder zurück die Soldaten
sind entschlossen das Gebiet zu halten
ihre einzige Hoffnung Waffen aus dem
Westen
wir haben sie etwas zurückgedrängt so um
zwei bis drei Kilometer
die Erfolge sind so gering weil wir
ausschließlich leichte Schusswaffen
haben mit schweren Waffen könnten wir
nach meiner Einschätzung das gesamte
Gebiet bis zum Meer befreien
die bodengewinne der Russen die vielen
Opfer auch bei ihnen und ihren Kameraden
das bewegt sie alle und das Gefühl dass
der Westen zu langsam reagiert haben sie
die westlichen Waffen schon bekommen
also drei vier Panzerfäuste sonst nur
alles was für den Nahkampf nötig ist mit
einer Reichweite von einem Kilometer
aber die Artillerie schießt 7 bis 10 km
weit
meint er die Russen
deshalb brauchen sie schwere Waffen so
dringend was heißt dringend am liebsten
schon gestern
wenig später es ist Ende Juni dürfen wir
in bachmund zum ersten Mal eine Einheit
der ukrainischen Artillerie besuchen
dort wollen uns die Soldaten eine der
deutschen Panzerhaubitzen zeigen die Sie
gerade erhalten haben nur zwei deutsche
Journalisten dürfen dabei sein das
Risiko dass die Haubitze entdeckt werden
könnte sorgt alle
das hier ist also die deutsche
Panzerhaubitze auf die die Ukraine so
lange gewartet haben sie haben hier ein
Modell versteckt tief unterm Gebüsch um
sie zu schützen von hier wird sie dann
an eine Position gefahren von wo aus die
feuern kann die Ukraine hoffen dass sie
damit eine Wende hier im Krieg im Osten
der Ukraine erzwingen können
Russland ist einer der Soldaten die in
Deutschland ausgebildet wurden 36 Tage
lang der Zeitdruck ist enorm auch
Russland glaubt dass die
Waffenlieferungen vielleicht zu spät
kommen könnten ja du möchtest ich glaube
es ist zu spät viel zu spät warum
wir hätten schon vor dem 24 Februar
vorbereitet sein sollen es war bekannt
dass die Russen uns angreifen würden sie
werden uns nie in Ruhe lassen wir hätten
rechtzeitig darauf vorbereitet sein
müssen
seit Wochen kämpfen sie einen fast
aussichtslosen Kampf einer der Soldaten
wir dürfen sein Gesicht nicht zeigen
führt uns ein Video ihrer Einsätze mit
völlig veralteter Technik vor
doch jetzt soll sich alles ändern mit
den Haubitzen aus dem Westen wo sie
eingesetzt werden bleibt streng geheim
du musst egal in welcher Armee der Welt
die Artillerie ist das erste Ziel für
den Gegner dass er aushalten will
denn diese Technik ist für den Feind
besonders gefährlich
es gibt nur weniges was wir an diesem
Morgen zeigen dürfen auch das Innere der
Haubitze dürfen wir mit der Kamera nicht
zeigen ich klettere alleine hinein
[Musik]
ja zumindest alleine durfte ich mir die
Technik drin mal angucken die Kamera
darf nicht mit rein das ist streng
verboten also das alles hier läuft unter
äußerster Geheimhaltung die Soldaten
sind ziemlich nervös wenn es darum geht
dass irgendwelche Bilder hier aus dem
Inneren der Panzerhaubitze
veröffentlicht werden
welcome to you crane [ __ ] haben sie auf
die Front geschrieben ein provokanter
Willkommensgruß an die Russen
seit dem Frühjahr seit April haben die
Russen ihre Angriffe auf den Osten
konzentriert
ist die zweitgrößte Stadt der Ukraine
ich besuche dort einen ganz besonderen
Ort als der Krieg anfing als es über der
Erde zu gefährlich wurde haben sich die
Menschen unter die Erde geflüchtet weil
es hier so viel sicherer ist
wir sind hier in der Metrostation Gerolf
truda was übersetzt so viel wie Helden
der Arbeit heißt die Metro steht seit
Beginn des Krieges still die Menschen
haben hier Unterkunft gefunden über 500
Menschen leben hier nach wie vor Sie
haben sich hier auf kleinstem Raum ihre
kleinen Wohnungen errichtet mit
Haustieren mit ihren Kindern die hier
den ganzen Tag leben die meisten
Menschen wirken sehr blass sie waren
lange nicht mehr draußen
Natalia lebt mit ihrer ganzen Familie
auf dem Bahnsteig die Kinder sind gerade
unterwegs aber die Katze ist da zur
Sicherheit hat Natalia sie angeleint
nein
sie ist schon die ganze Zeit mit hier ja
normal ihr habt euch daran gewöhnt ja
als ich Natalia treffe lebt sie schon
fast drei Monate in der U-Bahn-Station
ihr zu Hause ist im Norden von hakif
gibt es eine Perspektive dahin
zurückzugehen ich hoffe ich möchte das
sehr
wie ist die Situation dort jetzt ich
kann es nicht sagen
ich weiß es nicht wir werden nicht dahin
gelassen
die Soldaten lassen uns nicht hin
deshalb wissen wir nicht was da los ist
unerzogen vielleicht langweilig er
spielt hier
Alltag im U-Bahnhof es ist eine Szenerie
wie in einem dystopischen Film in dem
oben die Welt untergeht den Anschein von
Normalität waren das versuchen Sie alle
hier irgendwie weitermachen hinüber
retten was geht in die ungewisse Zukunft
[Musik]
am Ende des Bahnsteigs im Wagen Nummer 3
begegne ich Familie tischenko die hier
ihr Lager aufgeschlagen hat
warum habt ihr euch entschieden hier zu
sein in diesem Waggon
als wir gekommen sind gab es keine
Plätze mehr dann wurden die Waggons
aufgemacht und wir sind hier hergekommen
hier ist es ruhig
besser als da draußen
der brennt immer das Licht da sind viele
Menschen da ist es laut hier ist es eher
ruhiger wir sind unter uns
die Familie hat ihr Haus zurückgelassen
der Beschuss durch die Russen war zu
heftig deshalb leben sie jetzt auf ein
paar Quadratmetern trauen sich nur
selten ans Tageslicht
wie kann ich mir das Leben vorstellen
was macht ihr hier von morgens bis
abends
wie zu Hause auch morgens stehen wir auf
frühstücken die Kinder spielen ein
bisschen oben wir räumen auf
ein richtiges Frühstück gesundes Essen
das gibt es hier unten nicht die
fünfjährige anja hat sich schnell daran
gewöhnt ihr Bruder nikita ist 12 und
gerade aufgewacht er ist erkältet die
Feuchtigkeit in den Schächten hat ihm
zugesetzt
wie geht es Dir möchtest du nach Hause
vermisst du das zuhause hast du Freunde
hier ja
was machst du wie kann ich mir
vorstellen wie dein Tag aussieht
nicht so gut nicht so wie zu Hause
Anja seine Schwester ist wesentlich
gesprächiger
du bist schon groß aber gehst noch nicht
zur Schule nein ich möchte auch nicht
wie ist es für dich hier unten zu leben
ich habe mich schon dran gewöhnt das ist
normal
nein nein
wir hatten eine Katze und einen Hund
eine Katze und einen Hund präsentiert
wie ist das mit den Kindern hier ich
stelle es mir sehr schwierig vor hier im
Waggon
a
sie spielen manchmal mit anderen Kindern
schauen Trickfilme und wenn es ruhig ist
gehen wir vielleicht ganz kurz raus
ansonsten versuchen wir es uns so
häuslich wie möglich zu machen Wäsche
waschen putzen essen dann laden wir
einen Film runter schauen ihn uns an und
gehen schlafen
anziehen kämmen fertig machen und dann
machen sich Nikita und Anja auf den Weg
zur Toilette und zu den Waschräumen die
hier alle zusammen benutzen geht es über
die Gleise die beiden zeigen wo wir hin
müssen sie sind für jede Abwechslung
dankbar
[Musik]
und dazu gehört auch ein Angebot das
eine der Frauen macht die ebenfalls hier
unten lebt in dem Bereich in dem
Frühjahr Fahrkarten kontrolliert wurden
hat Lena eine Spielecke für Kinder
eingerichtet sie ist Psychologin möchte
das Kinder auch mal Kinder sein dürfen
inmitten der Schrecken des Krieges
wie kann man den Kindern erklären was
der Krieg bedeutet
ich denke die Kinder verstehen es aber
man muss einfach die richtigen Worte
finden um es den Kindern zu erklären
damit Sie verstehen dass sie auf sich
aufpassen müssen
dass sie das wertschätzen sollen was
neben ihnen ist
weil alles noch mal anders gedacht wird
heißes Wasser ist jetzt wunderbar
zurechtkommen in einer neuen Welt in
einer Welt die von russischen Bomben von
russischen Angriffen bestimmt ist vor
allem die Kinder sehnen die Kampfpausen
herbei dann können Sie hochgehen raus
ans Tageslicht ein Moment der Freiheit
den die fünfjährige Anja ganz besonders
genießt an diesem Tag im Mai in hakif
bis heute lebt Familie tischenko in der
U-Bahn so höre ich als ich im September
nach haakev zurückkehre wo nun wieder
täglich die Raketen einschlagen
schon wieder ein Raketenangriff mitten
im Zentrum von hakif nach dem die Russen
die Stadt die ganze Nacht über
beschossen haben geht es heute auch am
Tag weiter die raketenziellen vor allem
auf Infrastruktur und auf Wohnhäuser
und auf Kindergärten zum Glück war
niemand im Gebäude wegen der Gefahr sind
Schulen und Kindergärten noch immer
geschlossen
ich treffe Serie
einen Kriegsfotografen dessen
Arbeitsgebiet jetzt seine Heimatstadt
ist
das ist das Drama einer Stadt die
zerstört wird und dem Terror zum Opfer
fällt
im Kindergarten haben sie sich ans
Aufräumen gemacht können immer noch
nicht fassen was passiert ist
wieso sagen die Russen dass unsere
Kinder sterben sollen dass unsere Nation
vernichtet werden muss
[Musik]
seine Arbeit sichtlich mit auch er hört
von den Erfolgen der ukrainischen Armee
im Osten und Norden der Stadt auch er
schöpft Hoffnung auch wenn er skeptisch
ist dass dies jetzt wirklich eine Wende
im Krieg bringen könnte
nichts stört Russland
trotz aller Erfolge der ukrainischen
Armee werden sie weitermachen zu
beschießen
so ohne Ziel das Gerät
wo auch immer die Raketen fallen den
auch immer sie töten ganz egal ich denke
das wird so weitergehen
[Musik]
in easium überwiegt noch die Freude die
Erleichterung darüber die russische
Besatzung hinter sich gelassen zu haben
die Hoffnung darauf dass Terror Folter
Kriegsverbrechen aufgeklärt werden und
auch das höre ich immer wieder von den
Menschen mit denen ich spreche die Sorge
vor dem nahen Winter
[Musik]
ich denke dass uns geholfen wird den
Winter zu überstehen
wir konnten nicht in die Ukraine wir
wurden nicht rausgelassen wir durften
nirgends hin nur nach Russland ich
wollte nicht nach Russland ich bleibe
lieber hier und sterbe in der Heimat
damit wir freuen uns sehr dass die
Ukraine zurückgekommen ist ich bin
ehrlich alle freuen sich vielleicht gibt
es einen der sich nicht freut aber es
gibt immer ein schwarzes Schaf aber wir
sind froh die Ukraine wird überleben
dass sie ihr Land und ihr Leben
verteidigen können weiterhin das ist die
Hoffnung die so viele Menschen eint die
wir in diesen Wochen getroffen haben
dass dieser Krieg irgendwann einmal zu
Ende geht
[Musik]